hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tara's never seen and today
I'm watching the lego movie I'm pretty
sure for Tamara just saw I've seen
Ninjago and the Batman lego movie and I
loved the crap out of them but when the
first lego movie came out it just it
seems so cheesy and then everyone was
like it's amazing and then in true
chamber fashion I didn't see it I though
have incredibly real hair streaks in
because the lead female character and
this has blue and pink streaks Regina
got blue and pink hair streaks so I got
blue and pink hair streaks
I have seen Mean Girls I imagine this is
gonna be lovely I imagine I'm going to
love it and I imagine it'll be funny and
the cast will be brilliant because
that's what ninjago and the Lego Batman
was so let's just have a joyful time
[Music]
you
hey everybody you don't know me but I'm
on your computer or TV or phone so you
can trust me that was so cute I will say
I didn't enjoy it quite as much it
wasn't as magical as ninjago and Batman
were they think the Ninjago being the
third I think they really found their
comedy voice and that kind of tone and
then Batman was for me the funniest
character in this movie and so that they
took him and made a full movie about
that just took them elevating it so far
but this it was it was released and of
course as something that seems as
blatant as this did for this like crazy
Lego cash-grab it had a surprising
amount of heart I also will say the
animated stuff was cute and fun and
funny at times and if it would have
ended with just that stuff I would have
enjoyed the film for sure but it didn't
get really good for me until the very
end when we got into the live-action
stuff with Will Ferrell and his son that
happened at first I was like oh this is
so awkward
oh god movies that go from animated to
real-life can be a little awkward and I
love I love you raka dude
but they can be awkward and so at first
it had that kind of feel but it really
fell into itself that a good look
no so the film starts off and you see
the bad guy
and the good guy and the bad guy has
gotten the ultimate weapon what you find
out later is superglue at the time you
don't go so he gets the ultimate weapon
named crackle and then the good guy
rambles on this long prophecy about how
there will be a masterbuilder then you
get a great screen eight years later
screen not spongebob different different
and it is chris pratt's living his
everyday life trying to just fit in
everyone so everything is awesome song
finally makes so much sense to me it
meant to be that like tongue-in-cheek
cheesiness also kind of a bob i'm not
gonna like everything it's cool when
you're part of a team oh my god Shannon
was Superman Jonah Hill Green Lantern I
did not know that Shaquille O'Neal was
Shaquille O'Neal oh I did okay they do a
really good job with mixing in some
heart in film and especially at the end
of this one I really thought that came
in but you really get just punched in
the gut that Emmitt doesn't have any
friends or anyone that thinks he has
something that makes him special all of
the people that he considers friends are
like we have things that make us special
all right I like chicken me okay that's
my thing we all have things and it
doesn't have a thing and it's really sad
watching him come to that realization
and he comes to that realization because
he has been mistaken as the special and
he finds wyldstyle and he is trying to
now become a master builder or fit in
with the master builders too
save Lego ran there you whatever come
with me if you want to not die there's
different areas in this Lego universe
there's a West one and there's like an
underwater one and he was in like the
skyscraper one and she was like also
there's these that we don't talk about
anymore and Bionicle was in there that's
why you're all in trouble in the
diversity Bionicle in the gym six heroes
[Music]
wild style and Vitruvius are trying to
turn Emmet's into a master builder very
quickly he never gets there which I
really enjoy I love that it's not like a
training montage and then he turns into
this master builder no he's pretty much
just a mess the whole time but he's
really sweet and he uses that I just
wrote oh my god she's dating Batman oh
my god bad oh my god
all the master-builders gather together
to see what they could do to save the
lego universe and i love the mix of DC
heroes and then very generic people like
mermaid girl and generic space guy from
the 80s
swamp man was that a conscious decision
on their part or was that a licensing
thing and if that's the case I
understand because this film had no
right to be this good and it had no
right to produce to others like it and
so I understand it people Marvel was
like no they have Star Wars Legos and
that's always been a huge thing and they
made a brief appearance and I wonder why
they weren't in it a little bit more he
says the first lego movie there's Star
Wars Lego set sir it's such a huge thing
for Lego at least in my mind so maybe it
was a licensing thing that they could
only afford like the one scene of the
Star Wars guys it was really quick so
then they're attacked at through the
hull of Super Master Builders Jack comes
out he's like y'all ready for this he's
like oh no they were ready for that a
lot of things go wrong I honestly think
that they were in the animated section a
little longer than I would have liked
they would have been a little just a
little bit better payoff at the end if
it would have just like wrapped up a bit
quicker rule 1 of the C is never put
your butt on a pirate space and that
just makes sense they have a giant plan
to boil everything they're gonna take
all the robots out they're gonna go into
the relics room and replace them with
different things and they're going to
stop this super power
the kragle my favorite line and the one
that I laughed the most at is I made you
didn't let me finish
that was the most unexpected laughs I
love that line obviously his voice is
just then this biggest man got to build
a spaceship spaceship Spanish and then
there's just like a long long live
action scene I wrote the real-life scene
is amazing I really didn't expect it to
go they got me it took it from film to
maybe a little cheesy in the live-action
but incredibly full of heart and overall
just like the perfect layer of icing on
top of the cake of the Lego it was
really sweet
it was incredibly well done it had no
right to be as good as it was and the
the cast overall really brought it from
here to here I think they did everything
right to make the level the love of the
lego movie a level above other toy
movies john bailey says lego movie is
charming clever and fun for any age well
acted well-written and wonderfully
animated you will love it guarantee I
mean yeah that's basically totally
that's a great like condensed version of
everything I just said in the last 10
minutes
it was it was lovely and I really
enjoyed it and
I can't believe you're going to wonder
how this didn't even get nominated for
Best Animated picture during that
season's Oscars what
how did boss baby get inundated one of
your notes will be Oh Morgan Freeman is
there anything you say no to know my
note is Oh Morgan Freeman thank you so
much for the music unikitty will be your
spirit animal
[Music]
no now we're part of a team issues you
know
[Music]
I'm excited honestly to watch anything
that Lego puts out now because like I
said I think Batman was such a funny
thing because it was such an easy care
dream to write for he seemed effortless
in this one but especially in his actual
movie and the Ninjago really found the
voice and the comedic voice they were
looking for and so I think now that
that's been kind of established I'm
excited to watch anything they put out
thank you so so much for watching
everyone I will see you all next week
with tombstone my first Western ever
everything is awesome everything is cool
when you're part of the team
[Music]
[Applause]
you